dock you can ground me if I'm crazy
right oh sure half though I half the
ground anyone who's crazy then ground me
I'm crazy or not crazy why not
catch-22 as soon as you ask to get out
of combat duty you're no longer crazy
and so you have to fly more missions
that's some catch that catch-22 it's the
best there is read me back the last line
read me back the last line not my last
line somebody else read me back the last
line
that's my last line again oh no sir
that's my last line I read it to you
just a moment ago yeah I think you and I
are the only two sane people on this
base I have decided to race the mission
count from 25 to 30 we're gonna win this
thing
it doesn't make a difference who wins
the war to someone who's dead it's all a
numbers game and when your numbers up
your numbers up
this is war Oh war concentrates power in
the hands of those most likely to abuse
it well that was the agreement we had
500 goats
war is not about profits absolutely sure
not only I flown more missions than
anybody on this base and every time I
get close they raise it on Susanna's
headed balls blow I want to see I can't
do this anymore
you think this is a big fat joke oh it's
no difference remain you me happy happy
happy dead you worry worry worry can't
you see the difference
you